hi i'm brian with top notch lawn care we
specialize in taking overgrown out of
shape properties and getting these
properties back into a manageable state
today i'm going to take you guys through
the process of getting this overgrown
property back into shape
on this property here the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to blow
off the patio to expose what's
underneath there and to see what needs
to be done
walking into this backyard it was very
evident this property hasn't been
maintained in a long time i'm guessing
probably at least a year to two years
you can tell that by all the weeds and
the cracks all the overgrown edging and
the very tall grass in the lawn
then we are going to trim an edge and
then we are going to finish off with
mowing that way we can get all the
trimming and edging clippings back into
the lawn and mulch those up with the
grass
not only did we transform the backyard
we transformed the front yard on this
property as well
in this job in particular we had to move
all the furniture to one side of the
patio so we can get all the weeds out of
the patio cracks and make it look really
good
blowing off first is not something i
normally do on these types of projects
but on this project here i felt it was
necessary so that way i could see all
the weeds coming through the cracks to
make sure i got them all
so after that we're going to start with
the trimming and i started with the
patio first to get all the weeds out of
the cracks i started with the side of
the garage worked my way around to the
back of the garage and then just around
the fence
in order to not damage any of the
perimeter whether it being the house or
the fence we use the trimmer to get the
areas that the mower cannot
the rotation of the trimmer head goes
from right to left so if you trim from
right to left it blows the clippings
left back into the lawn
i started on the right side of this
property with the trimming that way i
can control where the clippings shoot
out if you start from right to left the
clippings will shoot out left back into
the lawn and that way you don't have to
worry about them
once the trimming is done i will move on
to the edging to clean up the patio and
the sidewalk the purpose for edging is
to give it a nice clean crisp look to
separate the lawn from the patio and the
sidewalk
[Music]
i will start edging on the right side of
the patio and i will work my way down
the sidewalk back up the sidewalk and
then finish off with the other side of
the patio
i usually just start on one side i'll
finish on the other
the biggest reason why we start with
this process of trimming and edging
first is so we can get all the clippings
from the trimming and edging process
back into the lawn so when we mow we're
not mowing multiple times and we can
actually mulch it up with the tall grass
after the trimming and edging is
complete i'll take the leaf blower blow
all the debris back into the lawn so i
can mow it up
the final step in this process is going
to be mowing the lawn
i always start at a higher height when
i'm cutting the lawn and then i'll go
over it a second time decreasing that
height
[Music]
most of the time my desired height that
i'm aiming for is right at three inches
be very careful when you're mowing an
overgrown lawn like this because you
can't see what's in the grass there's a
lot of things like debris rocks bricks
and sometimes even concrete and you can
actually throw stuff out of your mower
that could damage a house or a fence
[Music]
so lastly i'm going to blow off one more
time just to get all the remaining grass
and dust and reposition the furniture
back on the patio
from start to finish this job took us
right around four and a half hours to
complete
if you want a nice healthy lawn i
recommend mowing once a week or once
every two weeks depending on your grass
type
it was very satisfying to hear how
shocked the homeowner was at this
transformation